[Music]
everyone has seen the video they talked
about it
what was your experience with the
animals on the set my experience is that
the animals were treated great there was
no animal abuse on the side and that
that video that someone took and sold
for money and held on to it for a year
and a half until the salt for money tore
up for the films coming out does not
tell the whole story because I've seen
all the footage and it's edited and
manipulated and I think it's a scam tell
you the truth that was at the at towards
the end of the day and the dog was I
would not say in in the real context
that the dog was frightened the dog was
acting like a dog who was kind of tired
taking a bath hmm and was ready to get
out and in fact that's what happened
they took the dog out how does it make
you feel it makes me angry take the
truth because the others of the dogs
that I was on that set and I blossom
hallström has done several dog movies
and I know how he feels I know how
everybody on that set felt and how the
dogs were treated because I was there
never saw any abuse of any animal and if
there had been I would have walked I
certainly would not have been out here
supporting the film if any abuse had
occurred all the footage that I saw the
dog was going in the water
happily had to be restrained actually
from going in the water many times
during that day this was me and then
this was me then I came back as this
little guy I've seen the whole film like
twice now this is one of those movies
that will make folks cry did you know
when you're making it do you know like
this is the moment this you're gonna cry
oh you're gonna cry it's gonna well you
up I mean I got welled up when my agent
was just telling me the story about it I
had to tell him to stop I think I'm
gonna go and send me the script okay
because I don't wanna
breakdown on the phone but it but it
also turns around and it makes laugh
[Music]
you